In this lesson we discussed
the interplay between the geometry
of intersecting flat or
linear objects in space and
the algebra of solving
systems of linear equations.
We then use the geometric insight
into the algebraic process to develop
an algorithm, the Gaussian elimination
algorithm, for solving systems of
an arbitrary number of linear equations
in an arbitrary number of variables.
This is a valuable tool, since it let's
us solve a large class of interesting
problems that come up often
in science and engineering.
In future lessons,
we will develop vector algebra more
systematically looking at the problem
of solving systems of equations
in a different light.
As questions about physical
transformations of space.
We will then use this new insight to
develop more tools for solving problems.